-Welcome, welcome back
to the show.
-Hi, Jimmy.
-I miss you so much.
-We miss you.
-I watch you all the time.
So I'm used to you in my life,
but to see you in person,
I just love seeing you.
And congrats.
Looking gorg on the cover
of "Good Housekeeping"
right there.
Not too shabby.
-Thank you.
-I wanted to ask you,
because I watch you, seriously,
every single morning.
-Mm-hm.
-When do you get --
to get any time off?
-Mm-hmm.
-And do you go on vacation
when you do take time off?
-We just actually both --
-Yeah.
-I took a whole spring break.
-Yes.
-My first spring break
I've ever taken
because both kids
were on the same schedule.
So we took the kids.
I basically -- The last time
I took my little boy
on an airplane ride, he was 3.
It was horrible.
He was, like, basically
crawling under seats
and was like a foot rest
for the other passengers.
So I put him on a no-fly list.
-Yeah. It's good
that the parents do it.
-And, like, literally,
three years passed,
and I'm like,
"Let's give you a chance.
You're on probation."
So, we went
and we had best time.
He learned to swim.
-See? That's fantastic.
-Come on.
-I know.
So he's potty trained.
He learned to swim.
I'm like -- Drop the mic.
I'm done. It's over.
-Also, I should say,
he's 17 years old.
But that's amazing.
-It's awkward.
-Potty training comes
when it comes.
-But they always say, like,
"Your kid won't go off
to college with diapers."
I'm like, "Well, if it happens."
-This one might, yeah.
This one might.
I saw Jenna Bush Hager
was talking --
talking about this vacation.
'Cause she went with you.
-She totally busted Savannah.
She busted you out.
-No, because,
apparently, this --
it was your wedding anniversary
on your vacation.
-Turns out.
-Yeah.
You woke up and you had no idea
it was your anniversary?
-Well, what happened --
It wasn't the first thought
when I woke up.
And I don't think
it was my husband's, either.
And we took the kids --
the Hagers and our family,
we all --
we took them to the water park.
-Yeah.
And we're, like, on this, like,
bus to the water park.
And all of a sudden,
Mike's like,
"Is today our anniversary?"
And I'm like, "It is, actually!"
So it is.
-How romantic.
-Oh, I know.
We were at the water park,
I know.
Like, yeah, getting
waterborne illnesses.
-And how are the girls?
-Oh, my God.
Haley -- I've got -- You guys,
I have a 5-year-old
and a 3-year-old now.
They -- Can you believe
that they're that old?
-No, I can't believe
they're 5 and 3.
-I know. They both
recently had birthdays.
-And do you go all-out,
Hoda Kotb?
-No, let me tell you what I do.
I do something y'all should do,
because it's super easy and fun.
I make the best birthday cakes.
But let me tell you the secret.
Because we have this chef
named Elizabeth Heiskell.
-Yeah.
-She's like -- She goes,
"Hoda, look.
Don't be mixing everything.
Just dump it in.
It's a dump cake."
So, what you do is you take
the Duncan Hines --
Dump it in. Pour the egg in.
Barely stir it.
Just barely.
Stick it in the oven.
-Even with, like, clumps in it?
-Wait. Clumps.
No, the clumps
make it delicious.
And when it says cook
for 28 minutes, cook for 23.
-Julia Child, right here.
-Wait. When it comes out
of the oven, y'all --
And when I ice it,
people are like,
"Is that the cake
your daughter made?"
I'm like,
"No, that's the cake I made!"
But it is -- It's a --
-"My daughter did not make it.
I made it."
-During COVID, my kids don't
know that birthdays are a thing.
They don't know
that you have big parties.
They think that you sit
at the house, you have a cake,
and you FaceTime,
you know, with the --
That's what they think
birthdays are. I'm pumped.
-That is amazing. That's right.
They're that young.
-I am totally pumped.
-Yeah.
I -- My parents started
this silly tradition
of always getting me
an ice-cream cake from Carvel.
I loved it. Thank you, Mom.
Thank you, Dad. But, yeah, no.
There was a couple years
where they forgot,
and it's heartbreaking.
-It's like -- Yeah.
-Yeah, and then they go,
"Where are we going to get
an ice-cream cake?
Poor Jimmy's, you know --
Again, he's 17.
He's 17 years old.
Yeah, but I remember once,
my grandma, they put it in --
My grandma just left it out.
She just thought it was a cake.
And by the time I was
blowing out the candles,
it was just soup
all over the thing.
It was just a total disaster.
Well, there's a couple things
that happened this year
that I wanted
to talk to you about.
-Okay.
-I'm glad the family is good.
But you started off the new year
with a little con-troversy,
as they say.
Yeah. Hoda.
-Me?
-Yeah. A little con-troversy.
-Con-troversy?
-Yeah, con-troversy.
Because -- A little controversy.
-There's no controversy.
-There is.
-No, there's not. Okay, go on.
Tell the thing.
-I think you're going to
bring up what I think
needs to be addressed.
-Thank you. The polar plunge.
-Thank you for having the
courage to speak truth to power.
-Wow. Finally.
-Thank you.
-Everyone knows what
a polar plunge is, right?
This thing, you go in the
freezing-cold lake or water,
and you go in and you go --
-Can I set the stage?
It was 16 degrees.
It was freezing.
Jenna and I were
in bathing suits, okay?
-That's polar plunge.
-Wait. We had to go
into the ocean. Okay?
-Yes.
-Okay.
-Don't let her reframe --
-That's the polar plunge.
Everyone agrees with you.
Everyone, get your clickers out.
Do you agree?
[ Laughter ]
No, don't get your clickers out.
But then I have video of you
doing the plunge.
Here's Hoda
doing the polar plunge.
-Yeah.
-You take a look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on, Hoda! Plunge!
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Don't clap.
-Yes.
-They're clapping,
but I don't know --
Can we see that in slow motion?
The part that's
very controversial?
That's not the plu--
-Look at Jenna!
-Jenna is diving right in.
Jenna. You --
-No.
-You went with a --
You went with like --
-You dipped your head in the way
you dip a chip in guacamole.
-You did a "Sports Illustrated"
Swimsuit Edition.
You're like, "Wait. Hi.
Oh, am I in the polar plunge?
Sorry."
-That was not a polar plunge.
That was a polar dip.
-I'm gonna ask your audience.
Ladies and gentlemen,
did I do a polar plunge?
[ Audience shouting, "No!" ]
Wait! What?!
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad tuba plays ]
Wait. No?
-Wow! A mixed reaction.
-Oh! I thought I could
hype the crowd.
-No, but you can ask --
But did she look cool doing it?
-Yeah.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, there you go.
You looked really cool.
I did -- I got to be honest.
I did a polar plunge.
-You did? All the way in?
-Yeah.
Lake Michigan.
I went all the way in.
-Oh, my God.
-And everything freezes.
It was ridiculous.
It was in Chicago.
And I got out,
and I heard bagpipes and --
[ Laughter ]
-You thought you died.
-That's what Irish people hear
when they die.
And I go -- I thought
I floated away in Lake Michigan.
I go, "This is --"
But I survived.
There were just
actual bagpipes playing.
-Oh, you did it in a suit?
-Yeah, there actually
was bagpipers. Yeah.
-Oh, my gosh.
-You know what?
That's how you know
he actually did the plunge.
-It was a nightmare.
It was a nightmare.
Guys, I want to talk to you
about this big hall of fame.
This is a giant honor
for you guys.
Are you freaking out?
-The Broadcasting & Cable
Hall of Fame?
-Yeah.
-I mean, yeah.
We were like --
We basically feel like it --
That's how you know you're old.
You're just like, "Okay."
-No, no.
That's how you know
that you're a legend.
-There's no young people
in the hall of fame.
-Now there are two.
There's about to be two.
Let's talk about it
when we come back.
Savannah Guthrie, Hoda Kotb.
Come on back, everybody.